we've been talking about this new wave
of members of congress
uh men women muslims christians
immigrants american-born people
and it's great we want a wider range of
views and perspectives and backgrounds
in the house of representatives there's
been a concern
that the lack of experience that some of
these individuals have
may be leading to some bad ideas being
floated and missteps and that that could
be
a problem for democrats in the long run
and one of the people that is having a
growing list of these problems
is congresswoman ilan omar and uh two
weeks ago i pointed out to you
that her idea of a ninety percent
marginal tax rate on the one percent
meaning
starting at 421 000 a year
not only was it not politically feasible
it also wasn't backed by
economic data it muddied the waters when
we should really be looking at something
like
what alexandria ocasio-cortez has
proposed
and the general defense i heard from
people in the audience was david
illanomar was just spit balling it's not
a specific policy proposal
don't be so hard on her fine over the
weekend
she put out a series of tweets
referencing some common anti-semitic
tropes about
jewish conspiracy to self-enrich and
dual loyalty to israel
and she's already in the position of
having to apologize after being
criticized even by high-ranking
democrats in the house of
representatives
her first tweet was a quote of glenn
greenwald's
with the note added saying it's all
about the benjamin's baby and the tweet
from glenn greenwald
was about republican leader kevin
mccarthy
um threatening punishment for ilan omar
and rashida talib over criticisms of
israel
and what ilanomar responded with was
it's all about the benjamin's baby
meaning that the reason kevin mccarthy
is threatening them
is because of money related to israel
okay we'll get to that in a second many
people saw nothing wrong with this
but as we've seen a number of um
worthy commentators mentioned including
normal
trump critic brian class this is a
reference to an anti-semitic
trope when it comes to israel it's all
about
jewish money from the s in defense of
israel
but that same logic isn't applied to
other countries and people of other
national origins when american muslims
are questioned
about whether their loyalty is to the us
or to their
country of family origin for example
whether it's pakistan or saudi arabia or
whatever
we say that's islamophobic rightly so
but when the same is said about the
influence of american jewish money on
politics it's israel and we're supposed
to pretend
like these aren't just two sides of the
same coin now i'll get to
kevin mccarthy in this in a second but
let's uh look at the second tweet
from elon amar first in her second tweet
she quotes someone named bhatia angar
i don't know who that is who said would
love to know
who ilanomar thinks is paying american
politicians to be pro-israel
though i think i can guess bad form
congresswoman
that's the second anti-semitic trope
you've tweeted
and ilana mar quoted that tweet and said
apac the problem here for people who
don't get it
is the implication that americans
support
israel because of money period as
opposed to a host of other cons
considerations
which we can debate whether they're
worthy or not
the conspiracy that all of this refers
to
is the idea of jewish money as a tool
for global domination including the
control of american elected officials
like kevin mccarthy but here's the most
important thing
and this seems to be missing from most
of the arguments i'm seeing about this
on the internet
even if you disagree that the tweets um
are are furthering anti-semitic tropes
that's fine the argument is not valid
because this
all started as a criticism of kevin
mccarthy
who received zero dollars from apac
associates in 2018 so it's just
literally
factually wrong mccarthy was among the
republicans
who were spreading anti-semitic
conspiracy theories
about george soros paying for the
migrant caravan which of course wasn't
true
so i'm not defending mccarthy here he's
horrible
i've been criticizing the guy for years
what i'm pointing out
is that at a logistical level at a
factual level the criticism of mccarthy
as a sort of tool of the israeli lobby
in the united states
is not backed by evidence he received no
donations from
pro-israel pacs in 2018
and this just invalidates even the idea
of the tweet
now is ilanomar personally anti-semitic
i have no idea
i don't think this by itself is evidence
of that
but it's still destructive not only
because anti-semitism
is bad and playing up these stereotypes
is not a good thing
but it forces other democrats to have to
denounce her comments
which just gets in the way of democrats
getting things accomplished
uh whether or not ilana mar is
anti-semitic
nancy pelosi puts out a statement saying
this is bad
she needs to apologize chuck schumer
tweets
that this is uh irresponsible and
offensive
and anti-semitic and then the lana mar
ends up apologizing and more political
capital is spent on this nonsense so
what really needs to be understood here
are a couple different things number one
uh aipac is a more right-wing group and
jews in the u.s
are very very liberal so yeah there are
jews who support
aipac who vote in the united states but
look at evangelical christian support
of aipac and of israel that doesn't even
seem to be mentioned here
it's an important factor but then we get
to the bigger picture
you can recognize that this is playing
on long-time anti-semitic tropes and
still support boycotting israel
for example and the reflexive reaction i
saw for many on the left
to say this can't be anti-semitic
because they felt as though it would in
some way invalidate their support of
boycotting israel
or their opposition to benjamin
netanyahu separate the two things
you can be an opponent of benjamin
netanyahu
and believe that ilana mar here is
knowingly or unknowingly
playing up anti-semitic tropes you can
before
or against boycotting israel or israeli
companies or whatever
and still recognize that it's a really
bad idea
to even go near approximating these
anti-semitic tropes it's bad for
democrats it's bad for the progressive
movement
it's bad for those who want reform in
israel that's okay
you don't have to feel as though merely
admitting
that this was a mistake that it was
either ignorant or malicious and both
are problematic
and that doesn't change the validity of
your perspective on the
israeli-palestinian conflict or what
policy should be towards israel and i
was concerned before the election
that exactly this type of nonsense would
start flying after the midterms
and it has and it's only doing damage to
the progressive movement
follow me on instagram at david.pacman
and follow the show on
instagram at david pakman show coming up
next a cognitive
neuroscience perspective on why trump
supporters
support him no matter what he does no
matter what he says
today's program is sponsored in part by
sprezza box who are offering
everybody in our audience a bunch of
really cool free stuff
espresso box is a company based in new
york city and they are going to make
your life
a lot easier and save you money when it
comes to keeping up with men's
fashion because when you sign up for
sprezzabox you'll get a totally new box
sent to your door
every month with five or six hand-picked
accessories and pieces of clothing
you'll get things like really stylish
socks neckties
high-end sunglasses wallets watches
bracelets high quality pens and hair
combs
the list goes on but it's all really
nice stuff must-haves for any guy who's
wanting to
update his wardrobe i got some really
cool stuff in my sprezza box including a
money clip as well as a very nice pocket
square
and some really good looking socks all
of which
are very very cool the sprezza box
subscription
is just 25 bucks a month but you
definitely come out ahead
because every box every single month is
guaranteed to have items with a combined
value
of over a hundred dollars so they make
it easy to keep your outfits fresh but
you're also
getting a lot of bang for your buck and
it makes a really great gift for a guy
in your life
everyone in our audience can get one
month totally free when you click the
link
underneath this video and use the promo
code pacman that's p-a-k-m-a-n